pretty awkward watching that i have to
say um
veronique trillel noir to you first what
went through your mind when you
saw that video
it is unacceptable is uh
an unacceptable humiliation to the
eu's highest ranking female leader
and ironically if i may say so she
suffered this humiliation during a trip
arranged in parks to pressure
turkey on supporting women's rights
after turkey uh withdrew the
istanbul convention so it's really
shocking it should not happen anymore
and i feel very sorry for
mrs vanderlaan who is a very important
and powerful woman i hope
she's still he's miss box and what's
your
view on this as well and as we were just
discussing it feels quite extraordinary
at a time when
the eu's trying to pressure turkey on
women's rights to
have this snap well i think
overall there's going to be a lot of
little mistakes that were done
along this way that actually resulted in
this really really unpleasant and um
situation so i think the services should
have uh
probably test and and verify the
arrangements before that
uh but um what i felt and when i saw the
uh the videos of the event
it is more the underlying message
it's this subconscious reactions of both
presidents because they didn't even
think about
offering the president on the lion
the seat or even consider bringing
another seat i mean this
could be really sold very quickly but
that just shows that
that we still have two worlds one is uh
written on the papers and the other one
is in the hearts and it's
lived and delivered in the situations
where
your subconscious mind works more than
your rational mind
it's a point isn't there about how at
what point do we need men to
stand up and call out this kind of
behaviour
uh mr lenoir should charles michelle
have done more should he have spoken up
should he have refused to sit down at
that point
i i i could see the video you have shown
where nothing is seen during
the period where he sits down and she
doesn't
so i can't i can't say
more about it because we cannot see what
happens when
they they all realize that they are only
two shares for
three persons but certainly uh
the fault is in the on the side
of erdogan who clearly did not
even think about giving a chair
to the lady we have old photographs
showing
donald tusk as the president of the
council
and uh jeremy jean claudium as the
president of the commission
both sitting uh together
with erdogan so the fact that she is a
lady
is not a mistake it is clearly
the message that she does not have the
same
rank as a man so again it's
terribly shocking i see the argument
that you know this
lays at the door of the turkish
president
but should we not hold our european
leaders to higher standards
should the head of the european council
not have done more
miss bulks what do you think well
absolutely this was a lost opportunity
to demonstrate the european values in
action uh
so um i mean michelle should have
reacted differently but
he didn't so now this is a new
precedence and then we really have to
discuss it and i hope some actions will
follow
and we've been talking a bit about how
this is perhaps not something that is
uncommon for women
at the top of politics i think we should
be able to show some
footage of angela merkel uh the german
chancellor meeting
president donald trump i'm hoping
um unfortunately we can't see that now
but what the point i'm trying to make
is that this is it feels as if this is
almost par for the course for
many women leaders is that your
experience mr
lenoir well yes but not only in politics
before becoming a politician i was a
medical doctor
and it happened very frequently
that my patient referred to the male
students as a doctor while
thinking that i was the nurse because
the opposite was
very unlikely medicine
is men's world and i have experienced
the need for a woman to do
more and better in order to reach the
same
ambitions as men
things have changed since
the old decades i'm talking about
but still in the european parliament for
instance
uh some countries like mind
require parity but still there's there
are less
than 50 percent women in the parliament
and we probably have to speak louder
and do more and better to be at least
considered as
valuable so things have changed in
europe
not in turkey but in europe clearly but
we still have this kind of
examples showing that we really have to
fight for
gender equality a strong priority of my
political group in the parliament
yeah it's interesting isn't it your
experience in the kind of medical
profession too
i mean i've been in political journalism
for a decade in that time
you know people have asked me if i was a
weather presenter or makeup artist as
well i think sometimes the kind of
subconscious that people feel
um women in these positions kind of
comes out
and miss books is that something that
you've experienced as well
well uh certainly besides being a deputy
prime minister of slovenia i served also
as a eu commissioner for transport
and i know that one of the biggest
efforts during
our mandate was to bring more women in
power
on management and leadership positions
within the eu
and within the commission we managed
from 23 we went all the way up to the 42
percent
uh and we proved that in five years that
can be done but
there is a much bigger challenge on a
local level so even the country i know
best
uh we are seeing even the worst
situation now that we had in the past
you know women are disappearing from the
public life from the public post
especially from the posts
uh that deal with public money uh so
uh that's why i'm still very much in
favor for uh
of quotes uh quotas and
the quotas need to be exercised until uh
some sort of
uh balanced situation is reached and
then of course
you don't need them anymore and we have
uh countries in
uh the eu that prove the point yeah that
they don't need quotas anymore
so yes the issue is still
very much very much
needed and they we need to discuss it
and we need to address it in a
day-to-day uh
life and instances like this one just
prove
again what i said at the beginning that
there is something that is written
in papers but in our hearts and in our
minds uh there is
much more work that needs to be done
okay really interesting a discussion
with
both of you lots of broad points raised
there so much appreciated thank